Україна - це моя вторая батьківщина
волонтерство - це
мо внутрішн
півчуття Україна надіслала війська щоб
допомогти США боротися з алькайдою і
тому багато ветеранів вважають що
Україна була там коли ми її потребували
Тому ми маємо бути тут Коли Україна
потребує допомоги
[музика]
я вирішив що можу зробити більше
оскільки в мене є досвід конструювання
дуже люблю цих людей їх прагнення
свободи і все що відбувається тут через
війну стимулює мене
допомагати колишній віцеконсул Гвінеї в
Україні експолковник повітряних сил США
та інженер-конструктор з Румунії
Сьогодні ці люди з різних куточків світу
працюють на одному будмайданчику під
Києвом як волонтери хтось з лопатою в
руках хтось голіруч розбирає рештки
знищеного
рфбудинку немає
знакчени Я дипломат Я
президент організації або я бізнесмен а
я людина Я маю бути корисним я маю
допомогти тим людям які
м потрібно я не будівельник Але можу
принести могу подать могу резать
могу все зробите своїми руками Іса родом
з Гвінеї Він говорить українською понад
три десятки років адже весь цей час у
Києві він займав кілька дипломатичних
посад і брав участь у сотнях конференцій
та офіційних заходів присвячених
культурним зв'язкам України та Гвінеї
зараз він працює президентом африкансько
ради в Україні маю друзі які колись
працювали
миротворцями в тому числе працювали в
Африці І коли він мені сказав що працює
добровольчиї організації добробат я
сказав Я хочу бути разом з ними і
допомогти м за понад півтора року і
сасадіо діало доклав руки до відновлення
більше сотні будинків українців сьогодні
з командою волонтерів з Києва Він
розбирає завали у одному з районів
столиці куди в грудні поцілила російська
ракета з ісою познакомился Я
з ісою познайомився я потужно за цих
волонтерів Я взагалі не знаю куди їх
цілувати і як це тому що я не думав що є
така організація в Києві Ці хлопці я вже
їх знаю в лице Ви молодці звісно і
паркан тут вже було розбито всее лежало
в
сусіда
такому ентузіазмі Віктор Демченко вже
вчетверте зустрічає
будівельниківдобровольців у себе на
подвір'ї Точніше на тому що від нього
лишилося після обстрілу РФ половина
будинку та гараж з укриттям знищено
пенсіонер та його дружина дивом
вцілили ось це будинок Ось ця стінка
повністю була розбита і дах висів і щоб
дах не впав Ми вирішили з хлопцями теж
допомогли тоді блоки затягнули старі
почистили
йні те допомагають сильно тому що я не
знаю Як без них це було Как без них вот
это
было Сьогодні вперше допомагати пану
Віктору відновити оселю приїхав 57річний
Девід греков до приїзду з Каліфорнії рік
тому американець хотів долучитися до
інтернаціонального легіону ЗСУ оскільки
має військовий досвід в минулому він
полковник повітряних сил США під час
війни в Іраку він керував постачанням
амуніції на фронт А пізніше брав участь
у секретних спецопераціях з доставки
зброї захист України він вважав своїм
обов'язком ще задовго до
повномасштабного вторгнення
РФ Багато людей не зрозуміли і це так Те
що після терористичних атак у нью-йорку
11 вересня коли США увійшли до
Афганістану щоб знищити алькайду укра
надіслала війська щоб допомогти США
боротися з алькайдою і тому багато
ветеранів вважають що Україна була там
коли ми її потребували Тому ми маємо
бути тут Коли Україна потребує
допомоги вік та здоров'я не дали змоги
девіду грекову взяти зброю до рук у
складі ЗСУ він почав волонтерити і
доставляти на фронт аптечки для
військових а в перервах між цим
долучався до розбору Завалів після
обстрілів РФ у різних куточках
України Минулого тижня ми допомагали
розбирати завали початкової школи в
Києві звісно також донати постачання
обладнання Дронів одягу медичних аптечок
евакуація для цілих родин у безпечні
місця є так багато способів допомогти
яким би не були ваші навички ви можете
приїхати сюди в Україну і застосувати їх
свої професійні навички на
будмайданчиках в Україні протягом року
використовує Віктор буд він родом з
Румунії але вже 5ть років живе у
Великобританії і на момент вторгнення РФ
в Україну працював там Як
інженер-конструктор на пошкоджених
атаками Росії об'єктах Він допомагає із
плануванням роботи і долучається до усіх
задач
сам я вирішив що можу зробити більше
оскільки в мене є досвід
конструювання я виготовляв опалювальні
системи електричні системи багато разів
з нами були Волонтери які не мали
досвіду будівельних робіт тому ми
показували їм як робити подібне в мене
з'явилося багато друзів за один рік тут
дуже люблю цих людей їхні прагнення
свободи і все що відбувається тут через
війну стимулює мене
допомагати
ми з ним були разом в Миколаєві
розбирали від піску будинки іноземці
настільки часто доєднується до команди
українських волонтерів під час відбудови
що один з жителів Києва який працює
Разом із ними заснував власний музей
волонтерства у ньому він збирає десятки
подарунків і артефактів від небайдужих
що приїздять до України з-за кордону
допомагати з відновленням мы начали
колекционировать информаю ми Поли
колеціонути інформацію про іноземних
волонтерів які приїздять допомагати
Україні у нас є зі США з Фенікса з
Німеччини теж з нами
працювали ми збираємо те що волонтери
роблять своїми руками вони віддають
шеврони свої емблеми це цікаво буде
потім коли війна закінчиться будет потом
когдана зако навіть попри морозну погоду
взимку щотижня на кількагодинну роботу
на зруйнованих об'єктах в українських
містах продовжують приїздити іноземці як
новачки так і досвідчені охочих формують
у групи забезпечують трансфером та
навчають за участі фахівців потрапити в
проєкт відбудови можуть представники
навіть тих країн які не говорять
англійською чи українською був такий
випадок в нас був волонтер з Бразилії
він тільки
португальсько мусив з ним з телефоном за
ним
ходить з перекладачем в телефоні
показував перекладав Наша команда за
2023 рік виїжджала багато разів на
об'єкти і це більше 10 000 волонтерів
причому волонтери з різних країн з
Норвегії Швеції Франції Сполучених
Штатів е наприклад росcoйл із соt Lake
сіі який займається побудовою
соціального житла він долучався до нас
неодноразово це із Великобританії з
Нової Зеландії дуже багато людей які
долучилися до нас іноземці з якими
поспілкувалася ДВ під час відбудови
будинку у Києві планують і надалі
підтримувати Україну волонтери іноземці
Девід греков і Віктор буд що приїхали
під час повномасштабного вторгнення не
покидали країну з дня свого прибуття із
сасадіо діало якого життя пов'язало з
Україною ще 30 років тому каже що нині
він відчуває себе українцем украино - Це
моя вторая
Батьківщина я маю тут дружина Українка
Маю Ма тут донки якіе тоже здесь живуть
в Києві працюют и навчались здесь в
Киеві і маю зробити все соб якщо
можливо сприяти
щоби зупинити всю войну ну волонтерство
- це моє внут внутрішн ічуття У мене
немає громадянства України А я не могу
быти сковим Але можу працевати
добровольцем чтощобы
допомогти зробити чим змож щоб буть
[музика]
корисним